it's a crazy thought process to leave 10
years nba
grinding all over the country in
corporate america to go on reality tv
but it was that thought process
that actually changed my life somebody
in your family either side comes to and
says look let me ten thousand dollars
here's your answer i'm going to give you
10 000 it's a gift but it only has one
condition
you never ever ever ask me for money
again
everyone
jason i'm going to start you had a very
successful wall street career
and from what i can tell you basically
quit to go to reality television are you
are you basically out of your mind what
is the story there i mean that is like
the most fair question out there and i
think
i think that's a question that most
people that like abide by the system
would ask like why would you ever leave
this great job go on reality tv and it's
the same system
that kind of had me checking the boxes
promotion of promotion and i was just
miserable inside but on the surface
everything was good
it was actually probably breaking that
whole thought process that the systems
created
is what changed my life personally for
sure definitely professionally and
financially
and so i think back at it and what i'm
doing now with the platform of trying to
get people to like restart and rewire
the way they think about their career
development
and personal finances and what i've been
able to do in just three years with now
this platform
on restart reset instagram we're making
a million impressions a week and we're
making an impact on the way people
change their careers think about their
careers and personal finances so
it's a crazy thought process to leave 10
years nba
grinding all over the country in
corporate america to go on reality tv
but it was that thought process
that actually changed my life and i
think in the last three years kevin
i've with what we're trying to do i've
made a bigger impact
um than i could have in probably five
careers of being a banker
okay but the basic theory there what
you're telling everybody
and me is that you're able to monetize
social media that's basically what
you're saying right
correct i mean yeah precisely you're
able to monetize social media
and i think you got to take risks when
opportunities come to fruition i could
be a banker
any day i want to go be a banker set my
fingers today can do you have the chance
to like take a shot at
going on a reality tv show show every
day absolutely not and so for me
i was kind of unhappy with the career
and i'm like let's take a shot let's see
what happens
but you there's a lot of risk there
first of all you take a shot you could
have sucked and that would be in the end
right that's risk number one not number
two you may have never got traction
lots of people go on reality television
never get any traction on social
but neither of those things happen to
you you somehow found the path
just you know before i go to i want to
talk to caitlin about this too but yeah
what what number everybody's interested
is everybody wants to have a social
media base everybody wants to do what
you did
and tell me the number just follow us
let's pick
any platform let's just go instagram at
what point
did you say [ __ ] this is working
that's a it's a good question and the
difficulty in answering that question
is that based on like kind of your
engagement on instagram the ability to
monetize
could be drastically different you could
have an instagram account with 50 000
followers
and monetize much more successfully than
an account with 2 million followers
so there's not this like architectural
blueprint with instagram
for me rate i think when i did cross
like the 500
000 mark that was when i would say deal
size and deal
quantity was inflowing at a pace that at
that time i was
trying to keep up with as opposed to
trying to find more opportunities
all right caitlin over to you same thing
you've got reality television
background right and you basically
meet this guy and all of a sudden you're
two kind of
social media stars are you dragging off
each other is it like a jet one we find
the other and you're getting the
hydrofoil how does it i mean because
you're you're you're social you're a
social couple
and you're trying to create careers and
monetize them together
how does that work well i think we both
help each other in the best ways
possible like
i'm definitely not a numbers person and
i don't well i'm starting to learn the
business behind social media and how it
can be a business
and i'm more of a creative thinker and
social media has just worked for me
because
i am like what you see is what you get i
say inappropriate things i've just
always been myself
on my platform and jason has helped me
on the business side and i've kind of
helped him
be more of himself on social media
because i see the power and authenticity
and what that attracts people and it
keeps your
engagement up and everything with brand
deals love to see it so i think we've
helped each other in that way and
kind of have been able to
compartmentalize like that's
a business um but we can also use it for
fun
and engage people in our own
relationship and and
grow a business while doing that and
caitlin won't say it but i'm going to
say
caitlin was a social media powerhouse
well before her and i started getting
together and she had been crushing
everything she was doing within that
space well before so
that was uh much much before i came
along would you agree
well i mean i went on tv before you so
yeah but
i mean caitlyn when you started
television and you just
you know i i remember when social media
in reality television was frowned upon
because the networks wanted to control
the message and then all of a sudden
they started to realize that you could
push
eyeballs with social media that was
about six years ago
and now it's all about social media you
went through that transition i assume
right
yeah i was actually so it was six years
ago when i went on the bachelor and that
was really when instagram was taking off
and you did not know the power behind
like
what what could possibly happen or that
you could create a business or that you
could start things like that on social
media it was just
the unknown at that point so for me
i was really going on the show for an
experience
i didn't have the background that he had
i didn't actually have
education besides my high school
graduation
and so i was like there's really no loss
here for me and i would love to have a
platform and a name and like try and
get into hosting or doing something like
that so i was able to watch
social media really grow and i was able
to
have a really good team on my side
because
i went from you know working in a
restaurant
thinking like a hundred dollars in tips
was a lot of money
to a flat tummy tea telling me
tell everyone you poop out this tea and
you're gonna make 10 grand and i was
like
what and so i was so excited and my team
was like
absolutely not if you want the longevity
in some sort of social media career you
are going to turn down a lot of money
to build a really important um
platform and and that's the only way
you're going to do it is if you turn
down all this money so
i've seen social media go through a lot
as i'm sure you have too
okay so let's explore that for a minute
because that's fascinating so many
people would like to have the lifestyles
you both do
and sort of monetize social media but
you just cued on something that really
really is
turned out to be important one of the
factors that i think a lot of people
didn't understand about social media
just 36 months ago is that this
aspect of honesty particularly when
you're promoting a product people smell
[ __ ] a mile away so if you're being
offered 10 grand to poop out a tea
and you don't poop tea you know you
can't take that 10 grand is what you're
saying right
yes exactly and that's coming into that
world that was
a lot of money to say no to i mean it's
still a lot of money to say no to but
yeah that's exactly right and and once
you realize that
and and see the power behind
engaging your audience and having them
trust you is what's going to make them
loyal
and that's what keeps them around and
that's how you keep you know that's why
a lot of people come off reality tv and
crash and burn after because they're
just trying to make money in that moment
all right let's talk a little bit about
uh kaelin your wine business now i i'm
also in the wine business so i really
know how hard that is and i've been in
at it
for about 10 years and only started
making money four years ago
um my model's a little different than
yours you're selling through
big box retail you're in walmart right
yep let's let's talk about that model
you're basically licensing your name
but i'm going to make the assignment
just i'm making assumptions i don't know
the model but i'm going to make an
assumption because i know the business
so well
the best strategy for you is to partner
up with a wine
maker it has logistics to ship to
somebody as big
as walmart and then you brand it is that
what happened here
yeah exactly okay and have you told it i
mean how
how much work do you have to do to go
and get people to pull
a bottle off the shelf do you have to
actually show up for tastings
um i mean i would if it wasn't
quarantined i wanted to do that so bad
and go in there actually
no one's doing tastings right now
because of that i mean maybe they're
starting to again
but yeah it was i have a really
incredible team i have two business
partners that really
um have helped me navigate this whole
journey because again like
i i am the brand right like i everyone
knows caitlin bristow loves to drink
wine that
i've always wanted to create my own wine
label that um i have a very loyal
audience and my podcast revolves around
drinking wine it's called off the vine
and it just like was such a natural
thing for me to get into i worked in the
restaurant business for
over 10 years and i learned from
somalia's and i was
taught by them and i had to train
servers with wine pairings and knowledge
about wine so
i was always really passionate about it
and i think everyone again they could
see through the [ __ ] they knew this
was something that was like
a dream come true for me to do so it is
a lot of work
and effort but i'm so grateful for my
team because
they're the ones that are doing you know
well i mean i'm on every call and
you know but they're the ones that
really do the business side of things
and
um i'm just able to you know be the
brand and and push it through that way
because
social media again i'm reaching so many
people in different
um cities and different states and
it's i mean you don't need billboards
anymore and you don't need obviously
like i could just go on my social media
and say you know like
go check out this walmart and like i'm
going to go to a couple today
maybe i'll run into you and people go
out and buy it and i
really believe in the wine too because
it's all we drink
it's really good and i think um again
people just know i'm
super honest and and they believe in it
interesting story to
the social media aspect she actually
didn't immediately go to big box right
so she started going
direct to consumer through social media
built the brand they were selling
at a pace they couldn't keep up with
they then went through distribution
and they blew records out in british
columbia alberta
and ontario once they actually got into
stores
and so caitlyn put all the money up
front within the first year
she was profitable got her investment
back through a distribution
and when some of these big retailers
were seeing these numbers
and these endorsements from these
distributors and things that were
happening
they're like all right we got to give
this a shot so the the model from d to c
to being in walmart effectively happened
in less than a year and a half
yeah and all it goes back to that
conversation the power of authenticity
brand building
and being able to also use social media
to to
be able to promote to so many people
right
so caitlin's like bethany frankel except
nicer
yes that's exactly right i am canadian i
am much nicer
i know bethany very well so i say that
with a little
a little humor and humbleness but
so so jason back to you um
you know investing and understanding
investing
and you know now that i understand you
guys are contemplating marriage here so
we're going to get into that in a minute
um how do you handle that now
what do you think has changed in terms
of your wall street attitude versus how
you take care of your own money
and caitlin's what do you do i mean that
it's such a good
such a good question one of the the
difficulties i would say is
when you're w-2 when you're you know
working for a big corporation there's so
much security
right you know what check's coming in
when it's coming in you know your
bonuses
although those are subjective and that's
a whole different conversation
i think one of the big challenges for
kaitlyn and i is making sure that we're
on the same page with our finances and
that
we are while we're in this period of
being able to monetize an
accelerated rate the big question
everyone has to ask themselves is like
how long is this sustainable
so one of the big things caitlyn and i
do are like we are wide open with our
finances
and while right now income is at a point
that we probably
never expected we're keeping trying to
scale back our expenses
so drastically so that we can plan for a
longer period of time
from a financial perspective and i think
you know one thing
that's interesting that i'm going to ask
you a question actually is
we open our finances but now we're
starting to like look at a home and
we're starting to plan for our wedding
and things like that
do you have as the shark the investor
the you know
all your experience what type of advice
would you have for
us as we're trying to plan for both the
long term
and the short term in a world where you
kind of grew up in like entrepreneurship
of building a business selling it and
the ups the downs the highs the lows
like what insight do you have
so let me give you some advice that
comes from experience but also what i
learned from my mother who was very
pragmatic
when she was single and growing up she
was taking 20
percent of her paycheck and she worked
in a family business that made
children's winter clothing
and worked for her grandfather and and
they used to pay the girls in cash each
week
and she took 20 percent of it when she
was 19 years old
and i didn't know this till after she
died but she was packing it away
in her own name uh in in basically
telco bonds and the s p 500 stocks that
that portfolio
was there for 52 years and she was
married twice she kept it secret from
everybody
and when she died the executor called
the older brother called me and said you
got to come down here
your mother died a really wealthy woman
and i went
what i always wanted how she paid for
cars and university paid my own college
and took care of her own family
it never occurred to me that she was
investing this way
so she basically only spent the interest
and dividends
but over that period this thing grew to
a huge amount of money
and she was all about just taking a
portion of what you to make and setting
it aside
not saving it to saving doesn't make you
money you make point three percent
investing it i learned from her and and
now i apply it to sort of
marriage and i look at it this way i'm
when i got married
we had nothing zero dollars and nothing
at all and so we started the journey
together
we were pretty open just like you guys
but there's two things i would say that
i have learned
a woman should never give up her own
financial identity she should keep an
account in her name
credit cards in her own name as as the
guy should you need your own personal
identity
in terms of the markets because they
don't consider couples a financial
identity they consider individuals
and you know not you want to harbor bad
you know bad karma but
fifty percent of marriages in america
and the any canada and mexico end in
divorce within seven
years and it has nothing to do with
infidelity this is what's so incredible
it's never infidelity most marriages can
actually survive infidelity
but what they can't survive is financial
pressure and so
it sounds to me like you guys are doing
the number one thing is planning
together
because the marriages that break up it's
usually one thing
one of the two never did any financial
due diligence on each other
and maybe that other party was a
spendaholic or a gambling addict or
you know had had bankruptcy in their
family or had
some secret financial issue that they
didn't disclose
and it just completely corrupts the
marriage it's planning and saving and
it's really boring [ __ ]
but it's so important because the third
the third member of a marriage is
money i wrote a book on it i call it men
women and money and it really looks at
all of this stuff
and realizes that great marriages that
last a lifetime have a lot of financial
stability
if that's your plan you guys are going
to make it i got a question follow-up
question because i think we live in a
world right now where
incomes are just all over the places and
they're changing drastically within
partnerships
and so there was you know a point
several years ago i was making more than
caitlyn and there's a point today
kaitlyn's making more than me and who
knows in 10 years if that changes or
five years so what are your thoughts on
just the whole
idea of um like budgeting
and spending based on what your
individual
like entity like my entity is making
right so if caitlyn today is making more
than me
how do you think budgeting should be
like should it just be correlated to
your
only income should the couple look at it
as a whole like what's your thoughts on
that no here's how it has to work this
is the only way to do it okay
um otherwise you're going to run into
problems your your income and you're
right you're absolutely right
incomes are all over the map there's
capital gains there's income there's
royalties there's
you know your check from youtube if
you're running a channel all these
things are different
speaking gigs advisory businesses all
that stuff
so what i would do is buy a home
together
in your in your both your names after
you're married
after you're married it is an absolute
[ __ ] show to buy
property if you're not married because
there's just no way to resolve it
so you you rent until you marry and then
you buy a property in both names
but you keep your own accounts and you
both keep
you both have accounts you both have
credit ratings you both have your own
investments your own name
and then you have this third account and
you both contribute to it
to basically pay for the house the
mortgage all the things you buy for the
home everything you share together
all the money you spend on vacations
together you contribute equally
you know because you're basically baking
you're both in a business together
but you still have your own gig so if
kaitlyn makes more dough one year
because her wine's exploding to the
upside
good for her that's in her name and then
you
if you have something else going on
maybe you make an investment it's a huge
capital gain that's in your name
yeah now you're still married and you
could and i would highly recommend a
prenup that says we go in together we
know we've got have a number you know
what you're worth
and then you grow together and where it
matters is when you have children
because if you never have kids and you
divorce
it's much easier to separate the assets
you sell the house you've got your own
dough
and your own accounts and you fight a
little bit about should there be a true
up amount but it's not a big deal
but if you got kids all bets are off all
these prenups are worthless once you
have children because you can fight like
hell for
their support and they should get it i
mean you brought that person into the
world it's your responsibility
and so the way i look at it is
everything is 50
50 in terms of all the costs together
but you keep your own accounts in your
own your own investments if you wish
and that way if poopoo hits the fan
later it's very easy to separate
where people screw up is one of them
gives up their financial identity
usually the woman
very stupid idea very hard to get back
i mean does that not sound like common
sense that's i'm like why didn't i ever
think about the third account like
that's
it is complete common sense you're right
that's the third account makes so much
sense and even even we could do like you
could do like fun and activities right
like you go out for a nice dinner and
stuff you can just like use the third
account or something
one thing you both have that credit
heart you both have that card right
honey we're doing this off the off
off our combined account honey i'm doing
this on my own account because i want to
buy a watch and you don't need one i
have that fight with my wife every week
she says we don't need another watch
you're an idiot i said it's for me
it's for me this watch is for me i'm
putting it in often when i die along
with the other thousand watches
it's just one of those i love it now one
thing
one thing we i have a podcast called
train secrets and we talk get
uncomfortable or we get comfortable
talking about uncomfortable things
as they relate to money and just like
breaking the taboo of talking about
money
i think prenumps is like the definition
of that right like people here prenup
and they're like i don't want to talk
about but i think
getting comfortable with those
conversations saves so many more
headaches moving forward so
would you say obviously you just gave
caitlyn a suggestion in our situation
but in general
like do you think every couple should
have a prenup to some level or do you
think there
are certain thresholds or like what's
your overall take on prenups
100 get a prenup for one reason
it forces you to do financial due
diligence on each other it
forces you to ask the tough questions it
forces you to expose any weakness that
could eventually
you know kill the marriage off i mean
you really gotta when you do a due
diligence on each other
it's really something you're doing out
of love that's why i look at it you're
saying i'm making a lifetime commitment
to you and i want to know
everything the good the bad and the ugly
the crazy ants you have the nut bar
uncle all that stuff
i want to meet them all i want to know
what i'm getting into and i'm going into
this for 100 percent
because if you don't do that and that
that's kind of what happens
a prenup is sort of a commitment to
marriage you're forming a union
eventually look it's fantastic you're in
love that's so euphoric everybody should
have that
but 20 years from now the reason you
stay together
is you you built something together you
built something you know you've had
friends you have
a home you've got kids whatever it is
and that is a family you built and you
did that which is really a business at
the end of the day the reason the family
stays together
is financially sound i mean this this is
just pragmatic
and the way i look at it is a prenup is
the first step in that direction and i
think you guys should do it
and you know start your journey with
total disclosure
because you know what's going to happen
to you and i'm going to give you another
piece of advice right here
you're very famous and you're getting
more famous and you're going to get
married and people in your family for
both sides you're going to come and say
look
can you lend me 10 000 i want to start
this or i want to start that or
or i haven't have a financial problem or
whatever
you will become the never-ending source
of money to an extended family and this
is a big problem
here's the answer because it's going to
happen right after your marriage
somebody in your family either side
comes to and says look let me ten
thousand dollars
here's your answer i'm going to give you
ten thousand dollars it's a gift it's
not a loan
i'm never going to ask for it back but
it only has one condition
you never ever ever ask me for money
again
ever do we have that agreement that way
we're going to have great thanksgivings
together for the rest of our lives
we're not going to have to talk about
that ten thousand dollars you screwed me
out of
because i'm gonna write it off
it's sort of it's sort of and you do
i've done it multiple times
it's the right way to do it i don't have
this problem anymore i feel like you
know the karma's good i gave
money away i tell this to a lot of
couples because particularly couples
like you
you know they're they're making your
living off your brand
you just get bigger the more successful
you are the bigger you get and everybody
makes the example you know the
assumption you're stinking rich even
though you've got lots of expenses you
have to deal with yourself
but this is you know this is how you
keep families together it's really
really tough there's nothing worse
than a money dispute between family
members where there's blood involved
and money that never gets resolved never
i don't know how many times we're going
to have mr wonder here wonderful here to
give us financial advice i know you
haven't
you've so asked so much i'm like yes
everything you're saying yes no that
wow i have do you think that's advice no
yeah
i think it's amazing so much no no look
i i think it's a wonderful thing you're
kind of a
an example couple for a lot of people
out there let's just let's just uh talk
a little bit about how you met i'm sure
you've told the story 100 times but i
want my followers to hear this
it's it's different yeah yeah you want
me to tell it or not
yeah sure okay so so caitlyn was on the
bachelor and then became the
bachelorette
and then she was single and she was
doing her podcast where she travels all
over the country and i was
my banker self i was in seattle at the
time and she asked me to podcast and so
it just so happened we lived 2 000 miles
apart at that time we've never
lived within 2 000 miles of one another
still to the day we met
and she was in seattle doing a podcast
and she asked me to be her guest so
i went on her podcast as her guest and
yeah
totally had a crush on me though too
like i get that you brought a nice
bottle of wine
and two wine glasses and you were like
kevin can you blame me
no no absolutely not i'm gonna ask you a
question
caitlyn that you can give advice to
other women and and i i
i have a you know my own answer but i'd
rather hear it from you
how many dates should you go on
before you close the deal you know what
i mean
huh um i would say
like okay but the dates are like like
like really well i i i'll set it up for
you because obviously you go out with
somebody once
the only reason you go out again i'm
assuming is you were interested enough
on the
first date to say i want to do a second
to find out more
five's your number yeah five number
i can vouch for i would say three what
what what do you know in the fifth
day you don't know on the third no
you're just no after the third you're
just making them wait
you want to on the third but you're like
i'm gonna wait till the fifth i honestly
think
five is like if i'm trying to go back in
time i think that was
that's the number that's roughly i
wanted to at three and i waited to five
i think there's credibility right there
okay okay let's let's talk about a
theory about infidelity for other
couples to think about
now you know this is obviously a
difficult issue
but after you're married and let's say
you do screw around
i'm going to ask you a question what is
the right outcome should you immediately
wake up the next morning and disclose
what you did or should you try and make
it go away in the back of your mind and
never talk about it again what is the
right thing to do
i mean for me personally i wouldn't be
able
to put it in the back of my mind i just
wouldn't be able to sleep at night i
would feel like a monster
i would need to talk about it or i would
start
losing myself and i wouldn't be the same
person in the relationship
yeah 100 i don't think that could ever
like that
action there's no like just burying that
that just listen our world something
could happen if you found out a
different way
like i would just i don't know for me
personally and i think you're the same
like i just wouldn't be able to live
with it
yeah 100 so let me tell you what the
research
says this is a fascinating topic because
what i did when i wrote the men women
money books i hired
a lawyer and and his team to go research
this
to find out what the outcome was in
terms of divorce
on this topic this is not this is not
financial stress this is being
a cheater okay so it turns out and this
is fascinating
and this and i apply it to business as
well
you know when you are basically when you
lie to somebody
and you've never lied to them before but
you this time you decided not to
disclose that you screwed around
that always gets out it gets out
eventually it may not be
right away it could be years later but
because you didn't
come clean on it right away your
relationship is tainted forever
people if you started with 100 equity
between two partners
even though you everybody had fights and
everything else but trust is there and
then you come back later and say look i
wish i told you but i just it was a i
got drunk i was in a hotel room in san
francisco what and i just forgot about
it
that relationship loses 50 of its equity
forever
it can still go on but it's not the same
relationship
however if you have the balls to come
clean the next morning
and say i did something really horrific
last night and i
feel really terrible about it i swear
it's never going to happen again i don't
know why it happened
you don't lose a hundred percent you
still lose
but it's a it it eventually gets it's
like a per it's like a piece of sand in
an oyster it eventually becomes a pearl
because you were honest i was really
surprised to hear that data
um and they did it on about 600 couples
because there is a lot of infidelity in
marriage but i think
you know what anybody listening to this
could say is have the
guts to come clean or you will taint the
relationship that you worked so hard on
building in the first place
one thousand percent yeah you may want
to ask yourself why would you screw
around with somebody you love anyone
anyways what what's what's the problem
yeah there's a deeper issue there
and i think obviously every marriage in
the in the world
everyone creates different expectations
right like i've seen i applaud anyone
that can come back from
infidelity at once you're married but
like
i think with us and even for me with my
business partners too
is once once you cheat i just
you've lost my trust in gaining my trust
takes so much
so if it's a business partner after you
started your business if it's a partner
when you're married like to me i don't
think there's any like that's just my
expectation i don't think you can come
back from that i think you're the same
way
you agree but i applaud those people
that do have the mindset where they
could come back from yeah i mean if you
have kids i think that's a different
story
it's just all circumstantial i guess
yeah but yeah
well you guys are planning kids i assume
right yeah yeah
yeah that's another big financial um
issue there's no question about it but
you gotta you know i i think the
the thing about kids and i'll give my
two cents on this too i wish i'd had
mine a lot earlier
um and most people that get older
realize
i should have done it it feels like you
can wait
but it's it actually is better later on
to have kids that are a little older
when you're still young enough to enjoy
them just like you said you have kids
kevin i have two children one one one's
in new york
uh she's 27 the other is 23 in san
francisco he works for tesla
she produces television it seems to be
in our family somehow
and so how old were you when you had
your your last i
had children at 37 and i wish i'd had
them at 30.
yeah ah that's my problem i'm turning 36
next month and i'm already feel like i'm
so far behind
but i just it's so hard because i well
the good news for you is women
lots of women are having children in
their 40s but i would if you know you're
getting married and you've already been
together
i'd say chop chop get going i mean we're
kind of
yeah in that mindset so yeah last
question while we have you how do you
what is your strategy or plan for
budgeting for children
college expense everything so you know
what's really interesting that you can
plan for is your lifestyle changes
a lot you actually don't want to go out
for that first year
you're so fascinated with you know what
what is happening and
and learning you know sleep deprivation
and all that stuff and it's such an
amazing time
uh for that first child it's absolutely
great
that that would happen you know but i'll
tell you the problem is
on the second child that is
that is where sometimes one spouse has
gone back to work and your case is gonna
be even harder you're both gonna have to
keep your career going
because of what you basically do and you
know at the end of the day
um you're gonna find that
the budgeting aspect is not as hard as
you think because you're so
sucked into the whole first year second
kid
i didn't even sleep with my wife for 12
months i couldn't take it i was working
so hard
i had to have sleep and there is no
sleep if you have a one-year-old and you
got a newborn or two two-year-old a
newborn
you're [ __ ] i mean you're you're only
sleeping four hours a night if you're
lucky and i'm not gonna do all of that
you know
that's gonna be i don't know it's gonna
be on one of you guys i mean you know so
you slept in a different bed
we did i'm just disclosing the facts and
i've talked to lots of other couples
that have had two or three kids they've
all done the same thing
oh i know we know a lot of couples that
do oh yeah yeah
sleep deprivation is a [ __ ] like
you can't make you can't make money when
you can't think
and you need and you need you you really
need seven hours
during a 24-hour period it's really hard
to get when you're raising kids
but but i would say that you have to
think about a child that's costing a
quarter of a million dollars
by the time they get to high school and
it's really
expensive in terms of just the cost
allocation it's an
investment yeah you know in the old days
they used to put them to work when they
were 15 to try and get back some of that
money
if that was like the point of having a
family it was like a
no business look but but i think it's a
wonderful thing in life if you can do it
it's worth it
but i again you're going to be kind of a
model couple in terms of
of so many people and i you know that
that see a couple making a living off
social media and building personal
brands are going to be
that they'll they're going to be very
jealous of what you guys have done
and i think it's remarkable that you
know you would have taken a career
of wall street and said screw that i'm
going to take a chance in a very highly
volatile industry
television's a crazy business i don't
have to tell either of you that but you
manifested it to something great and i
think we should
take stock and be pretty proud of you
guys it's pretty good yeah yeah and i
think you create an insurance plan in
life through education
and skill set when you have an insurance
plan you can go out and take those kind
of risks because you can always fall
back on what's there
and another interesting fact i just
interviewed the ceo of viral nation it's
the largest social media agency in the
world and based on their statistics 86
of kids growing up right now aspire to
be
influencers and when he told me that i
was just
blown away and he's like you can't be a
politician anymore without having a
social media presence
you can't be you know you just listed
all the different careers
that you must have some sort of social
media presence to be in and it's
it's a wild world we live in we're
fortunate to have one another
let's let's end it on this each one of
us give the top three things you have to
do
to be successful on social media you
know how many people be interested in
hearing that from each of you
just just top top three things that
could be completely different
okay let's start with you i i would say
authenticity uh being honest um
i would say turning down money
to stay true to that authentic self and
and build something and then three top
wait what was the question again top
three well you're somebody
we know that 80 plus percent of people
want to be influencers i'm asking you
what are the top three things you have
to do successfully
and even have a chance of becoming an
influencer
and i think it's about paying attention
to your audience and to
who is like doing polls asking questions
involving them because that's who
is gonna like you know stick around if
you're paying attention to what those
people
want to see what they want you to be
selling what they like
if you listen to those people that are
following you you will build it
eventually and get their trust that's
good yeah i think my top three things if
people are trying to build a social
media presence or
maybe increase their brand awareness or
small business they own the first is
you got to identify your niche like what
differentiates you from
everybody and how can you make something
impactful what makes you you
and that's what i'll call your niche the
second thing i would say
is the quality of your content and i
think caitlyn alluded to it but finding
ways to engage your audience
putting just really good quality stuff
out there you can't throw [ __ ] at the
wall and hope it sticks it's got to be
uh well dude you are one of a kind and
it does stick it's unbelievable
the third one i would say is uh
consistency
right so you can't just like have this
idea this dream do it for a week and
then be gone
people are if you're gonna do something
every monday they're expecting it every
monday at that time you got to be
consistent
with what you're doing those are my
three yeah how about you kevin
i i would i would say what i've learned
over these last six
years is that each platform is different
and constantly evolving
and you have to be a constant student of
the little
changes that are occurring i'm not just
talking about algorithms i'm talking
about the
consistency of your message on these
different platforms and
who's out there i mean twitter's
completely different from me than
instagram is than facebook is that
linkedin is and now i just started
last week on tick tock it was not a
platform i thought i was going to
get into but i'm starting to watch what
it's doing in the 18 to 34
barstool kind of demographic and
realizing i have to be there too
and so to me it's it's it's half art
as caitlyn said you got to have fun on
it and it's half science
and and it is the engine of of
monetization it really matters and i
totally agree with caitlin on the no
[ __ ] i mean the minute you get
caught
you know just being a scumball
salesperson i think you
you just you're you're done yeah there's
no margin for error
yes i think you're good to go cancel
culture stuff you get cancelled
yeah yeah the tick tock thing i think is
brilliant is because if you're an early
adopter there's going to be a next
social media thing and if you're an
early adopter
some of these kids like were in college
they were the first people on tick tock
they started dancing they dropped out of
college and now they're making millions
and millions of dollars
on tick tock so that's being an early
adopter
it is interesting but i actually talked
to the tick tock executives last week
along with uta you know my agency
because i wanted to go into it from the
scientific portion and they said
what really matters on their platform
for everybody listening here is original
content
in other words it's got to be vertical
it's got to be 59 seconds it's got to be
original
they don't want to see reposts off
twitter off instagram on facebook they
want
original and that constituency really
cares about that stuff
if they see the same stuff on every
platform they just blow you off in the
way that algorithm works that's really
good information
and so tick tock takes an additional
amount of time to everything else you're
doing
but it's a new vehicle a new platform
for many of us and i think you know
caitlin for you and your wine stuff
i think you should really drill down dig
in yeah
i'm trying on the tick tock you're doing
good with it yeah
yeah i just sounded so old on the tick
tock
but yeah yeah you're right well listen
guys i really enjoyed it this was
fascinating i wish you the best of luck
and we'll have to
what we'll do is we'll do it again we'll
check in after the marriage
and uh we'll see how all that went you
know
i i have to tell you i'm huge in the
wedding industry i'm an investor in
honey fund and
you know one of the biggest greeting
card companies and
i've been doing the wedding gig for
years and years and years and it's
really changed the one thing i would say
is the average wedding in terms of
dollars spent
is down 50 because people are doing
smaller more intimate weddings and then
holding parties afterwards
now whether that changes out of the
pandemic but right now there hasn't been
a lot of weddings for 200 people in them
yet
it's gonna take time yeah
i think there's some people trying to
make up that lost revenue
with us well you guys have an
interesting opportunity
you can actually have your wedding
sponsored
because of who you are and you may want
to make it a
big deal and you would still be credible
with that because that's where you came
from
right it's a crazy i'm going to end on a
bachelorette story because
kenny the the director of shark tank
so kenny is also the director of
bachelorette so one night we were
shooting shark tank in culver city said
hey kev
you want to come for midnight the girls
are coming in for the first time tonight
you can come and watch it happen
now as you know there's plenty of
libation on the set
i've been working for 10 hours and i got
up there and i hit the bar
i really hit the bar i was liberally
hitting the bar
and then when they started shooting i
started cruising around
right on the set giving advice to all
women
and kenny freaked out he said
is that is that mr wonderful walking
around in the middle of the show
when was this remember this was this was
six years ago and i got banned for life
i got kicked off the set at the
mansion i can never go to the
bachelorette again
i'm legend i'm legend there that tape is
a legend i walked around giving advice
i i'll have another drink you know it
was just it was and that's when they
didn't have the two drink limit you the
bar was just free-for-all at that point
oh that's so fun for a while i was the
bartender it was just getting that much
fun
maybe something here that's awesome we
should bring you back as the bartender
yeah maybe i can make a guest appearance
again i'm going to do a plug first a new
show i just finished taping
at telemundo because it actually applies
to what we've been talking about
it's called money court and it's all
about disputes of money between family
members business partners landlords
tenants anything to do with money i
actually have a federal judge adapozo
and a trial attorney katie fang as my
partners and we hear the cases
think about it's sort of judge judy on
steroids because these are real
litigations
and i taped six apps i can't believe how
crazy it was it starts airing
august 11th right after the olympics on
cnbc
tune in everybody that's just a
shameless plug for a new show
i have a lot of respect for judge judy
because she built this a massive
franchise i wanted to take it more
in the business direction which is
really my domain so
i'm trying to i'm trying to stop
partners from suing each other get their
business back on track because nothing
destroys value
like litigation and a money dispute so
it's brutal if you like that video
where did you see my next one don't
forget to click right over here
and subscribe